hey what's up guys My Name Is AO welcome
to episode six of game programming Okay
so yesterday we had a huge episode that
I definitely don't have time to ever
repeat ever again um so this episode
will be short but we but we will
actually be displaying something today
we're going to want to do something
really simple um essentially um we're
not going to talk too much about this
but what we're going to do is basically
fill the entire window black so at the
moment what we've got if we just launch
our game we've got um well we've just
got this blank window and as you can see
it's it's literally just an window
there's nothing filling it there's no
graphical anything in here like Graphics
are not being used this is just this is
just the standard jframe um you know
layout I guess um so what we're going to
do do today is actually initialize and
you know start rendering a black um just
black pixels really to the uh to the
screen so we'll do that
um uh doing a few things first of all
and I will discuss everything here um
what we need to do is we've created this
buffer strategy and what we need to do
now is this buffer strategy is sweet for
handling buffers but what we need to do
now is actually apply data to the
buffers right because at the moment
we've got an empty buffer we've got
we've got triple buffering on but
they're not accepting data yet so we
need to actually start um getting them
to accept data or essentially um I guess
a different way to put this would be to
actually um rather apply the buffer to a
graphics object so all we need to do is
type Graphics G now we'll call it J
because well first of all that's a
convention but second of all it's just
you know J is going to stand for
graphics no point typing Graphics here
Graphics J is going to equal BS so our
buffer
strategy do get draw
Graphics okay so what does get draw
Graphics do get draw Graphics um
essentially what it does is it is it
creates a l link
between Graphics to which you can write
data unless just import it by the way um
it's basically creating a link between
Graphics so in other words it's creating
a link between you being able to
actually draw Graphics to the screen and
the actual buffer strategy okay so it's
linking the two together it's um I guess
it's like it's it's creating a graphics
context you know for for the drawing
buffer um so that's set right what we
also need to do is now that we've in
between here and here before we type g.
dispose I'll explain this in a minute
this is where and you could even like do
a little
um uh thing for yourself so that you
know I'm not going to do that though um
but in between here and here is where
you do all of your graphics so any
graphics that need to be displayed on
the screen must be displayed here before
you call J do dispose so why are we
calling J do dispose and what does it do
dispose does exactly what you think it's
going to do it just it just disposes of
the current Graphics now what it does is
it essentially releases all your system
resources so as you can imagine render
is in a loop so what's happening is
every time you're setting Graphics equal
to the buffer strategy what you're doing
is every time you're actually creating
Graphics but at the end of the frame you
need to remove those Graphics otherwise
as you can imagine the graphics from
each frame aren't going to be removed
that's a problem because that will just
crash your game eventually after after
we render every frame we want to um we
want to remove uh the graphics that
we're not using anymore so we do that by
disposing of the graphics and finally
what we need to do and this is very
important because not only will your
game not work if you do this it will
crash you need to actually show the
buffer now last last time yesterday I
explained that what happens is I'm not
going to bring up paint again I don't
have time but yesterday I
explained that what happens is with
buffers you have your screen and then
you have buffers that actually render
and contain images now we need to swap
the buffers essentially it's called
buffer swapping um or blitting you could
call blitting as well
um basically what what it's going to do
is it's going to swap the buffers
and you know remove that that image that
we had last time and I'm sorry I've got
rss's on
um oh you guys probably w even say that
cuz I'm not I'm not recording in full
screen well I am recording in full
screen but I'll be zooming in so um
yeah um essentially what you'll be doing
is uh swapping out the buffers so the
buffer that needs to be rendered right
it's already like it's already computed
but it's not being displayed what we
need to do is actually you know make I
guess this next available buffer object
actually visible we need we need to
display it if we don't right it's going
to still take up memory and it's just
game's not going to go anywhere and
that's a huge problem so we actually
need to be able to release the memory
and move because remember a buffer a
buffer is a place for temporary storage
we can't keep file we we can't keep um
objects and graphics and pixel data
there forever we need it's it's only
temporary it it'll literally be there
for probably like honestly maybe a few
Nan seconds a few um a few milliseconds
um again I'm using nanc really Loosely
here cuz nanc is obviously a very very
um tiny uh you know section of time um
but I'll just say milliseconds um it
might be less than 1 millisecond that's
what I say there but anyway point is for
a period of time very very short period
of
time we we're actually calculating which
pixels need to go away and then we're
displaying them straight away now we
need to we need to actually clear the
memory and display that those pixels to
the screen and we do that by actually
showing the buffer strategy essentially
so we called BS s buffer strategy. show
show and what this will do again is it
will make the next available buffer
visible it will show the buffer that's
been calculated now to make the screen
black remember I said that we do all of
our Graphics here to make the screen
black all we need to do is first of all
it's going to work by filling a
rectangle so if we call G so graphics.
fill wct it will actually fill a
rectangle um with a specified color and
again we Define the size of that
rectangle so we Define the starting x
and y coordinate which is 0 0 0 x and 0
Y and then the width and height of the
actual rectangle so because we want to
fill it full screen we want the width to
essentially be the same width as our
width of our window which is actually
width time scale so you could type width
time scale here I'm simply going to put
get width now what get width is is it's
a it's an integer um method it returns
an INT it returns an integer all it does
is it's part of the canvas class and
possibly even the component class
actually I'm not 100% sure on that it's
yeah it's part of the component class um
essentially what it does is it just
Returns the size of our window so get
width is probably the best way to ensure
you actually fill the entire width and
again for height we'll just do get
height so in other words what this is
doing is is filling a rectangle
starting from the point 00 which is the
top left corner right not the bottom
left corner the top left corner uh in
Java if we get to openg which we will
eventually maybe not in this series
though cuz I I did promise keeping it
library free and making it from scratch
but maybe in like a future series or
something because you guys have Begg
have been begging me for like a year to
do open jail
um in openg and stuff like that is
actually the bottom left corner that's 0
but in Java and other computer
science stuff it's the top left so it's
filling a rectangle from the top left
coordinate of 0 0 and the size of that
rectangle is width time is width by
height it's going to fill the whole
screen now it is filling a rectangle but
we don't know what color it is yet so
what we can do is actually just before
that remember you do this before you
fill the rectangle we want to actually
set the color so we simply call G do set
color and again we'll just go color.
black and uh there we go it's going to
set the color of it's just going to set
the graphical color to be black and then
whatever follows this will have that
color applied to it so fil rectangle
will have black color applied to it and
uh that should be it so remember our
game is being started we're hitting
we're hitting um up run equal true where
okay actually this is a question I want
to address right now um you guys are
wondering how is the run method called
we don't actually call the run method
anywhere why where is it called and what
happens is because game implements run
rable right what happens and it extends
canvas what happens is because it
implements runnable and we've said new
thread to be this when we start the
thread it's automatically going to run
the run method is that clear cuz that
sounds pretty clear to me um so yeah
that's what's going to happen and again
we're in a loop so we'll be rendering
and that's how this method gets called
so yeah let's just hit debug and we'll
see what we get all right so I can hear
my graphics cards squealing right now
cuz it's probably rendering this at
100,000 frames per second uh which is a
good sign but what's happening is you
can see that we've got a black uh screen
right now and the thing is like this
isn't just we we haven't just changed
the color of the jframe background we
have we haven't just changed the color
of the background to be to be black um
we're actually fullon using the graphics
card to actually render an array of
black pixels onto the screen we're
actually using the graphics card here to
fill to actually render an image to the
screen so effectively that's pretty much
the first step so um try it out for
yourself you guys can have fun changing
the colors to whatever you want if you
want a specific color um you don't have
to go color dot cuz obviously there's
like a limited amount of colors you can
choose from here what you could actually
do here is Select something like new
color and then in here you just enter
the RGB values so something like I don't
know 80 red 40 uh 40 green and like
maybe like uh 100 blue blue for example
that would give us oops did that twice
that will give us this nice purple color
for example all right I'm just going to
leave it as black though um cuz that's
how I
roll and um yeah next time we'll
probably take a look at actual
individual pixel manipulation and stuff
like that and um again I'm going to try
and keep these episodes short I'm sorry
uh I'll try and keep them below 10
minutes definitely so yeah I hope you
enjoyed this episode of game programming
if you did please hit that like button
lets me know that you guys are actually
appreciating the series and uh I'll see
you guys later
[Music]
bye